your advice to anyone who wants to lose
weight
via hooping ah yes excellent question
so um there's a lot of hooping companies
out there that would have you believe
that
standing in front of your tv and hooping
for 15 minutes
a day is going to help you lose weight
and then there's a lot of people that
are being disappointed because they do
that and then they go what's
what's going on so um for any
any activity you've got to sweat you've
got to push yourself you've got to
stoke your passion and put a lot of
energy into it so
if you're only going to hoop for 15
minutes a day which i don't recommend i
recommend at least half an hour
you got to hoop breakneck speed like as
fast as possible but with good form so
it is
you know you do want to have like a good
dvd or have like
one or two lessons so that you make sure
that you're hooping in a balanced way
and then from there like break next
speed for like
you know 15 minutes and then maybe 15
minutes of relaxed
hooping that will that'll you know stoke
your your inner fire
and help you lose weight and of course
you know don't eat a bunch of
big macs and french fries and you know
stuff like that there's no magical cures
what i'm saying
but hooping can be the most fun way of
being fit and being in your body of any
of them if you really
still you know let yourself sweat and
really get into it
get excited about it so it's still a
lifestyle
change as well it's not just it's
hooping along with
eating right and i mean you could get
away with eating a bunch of big macs and
cheeseburgers if you really hoop like
your
butt off every single day but you're you
know your organs will be happy so
you know eat a good dessert salad you
know
like yeah lots of water yeah
you